hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and dr. strange
has been out for a little while now and
like any Marvel movie it definitely has
plenty of little Winx and Easter eggs
throughout the film honestly it was just
two hours of me and the theater shouting
I guess the Living Tribunal
oh of course the wand of watoomb no
you're causing a disturbance but beyond
all the references of the comics there's
actually way more cool details that are
hidden throughout this movie like with
the visual effects and the story and how
it was all made stuff that a lot of
people aren't really talking about so I
wanted to dig even deeper and break all
this stuff down for you guys along with
all the other connections I'd I notice
now I already made another video that
explained the ending and the recurring
theme of time in this movie as well as a
breakdown in the post-credits scenes so
definitely check those out when you get
a chance but for now let's open our I
know this isn't a green screen what what
did this get here
no you're commenting a disturbance now
before the movie actually begins we see
the new Marvel fanfare the first time it
appeared in front of a Marvel movie we
actually saw this last July at Comic Con
and it's great there is images of all
the Avengers the MCU heroes that we've
seen so far with quick glimpses of Nick
Fury's quote from The Avengers Tony
Stark saying I am Iron Man
Black Widow sane and got red in my
ledger and I would say it was especially
important to establish this story as
part of this universe using these images
since Doctor Strange was so
aesthetically and narrative ly different
from the rest of the MCU like no one's
gonna think back on strange in that
astral realm fistfight and thankless
that in Winter Soldier or age of Ultron
so I'll get into the other ways of this
movie set itself apart as we go but for
now this fanfare was really great about
establishing strange as one of the guys
and part of what makes this fanfare so
great is the music
and the composure behind it was Michael
Giacchino who composed this entire film
now I'll come back to him in a bit but
let's move on to this opening scene in
the Kumari Taj Library which introduces
us to kycilia played by Mads Mikkelsen
now the character of kai Caelius is
actually a way less significant villain
in the Marvel comics he's actually just
kind of a servant to Baron Mordo
but since Mordo is mostly a good guy in
this movie his script bored a lot of his
plot points and reassigned them to Kai
Silius so he's a former student of the
ancient one who seeks greater power
stealing the book of Cagliostro to
betray and defeat the ancient one and
fun fact Kai Silius was named after the
word Kai Cillian which is a rare
snake-like amphibian I guess you can see
the resemblance now this book of
Cagliostro was written in the late 18th
century and it contains spells of
mystical knowledge from all around the
world
it's named after Cagliostro an Italian
sorcerer from the 1700s and there's more
I want to talk about in this library but
I'll come back to it later instead let's
move on to this awesome fight scene
between the ancient one and Kai silliest
and all of his elet followers in London
now we pointed out in our breakdown of
the trailer that this is Northumberland
Street but what I love about this is
this is the same Street featured in the
BBC show Sherlock starring Stephen
strange himself Benedict Cumberbatch
actually at the end of the street is the
Sherlock Holmes pub see the converse is
already collapsing in on itself also
notice how kycilia screams this at the
ancient one this is a really subtle
foreshadowing of the fact that the
ancient one derives her power from the
Dark Dimension the same place that she's
trying to stop kycilia is from bringing
into this dimension this is a big reveal
later in the movie and it's cool that
the script sets it up in these opening
moments and of course the visuals of
this fight look amazing the visual
effects supervisors to find surrett ii
pulled from a ton of references to piece
together these i popping visuals and he
said that one of the starting points was
the Christopher Nolan movie Inception
but Cerreta said he wanted to make it
look 10,000 times more dynamic and on a
much bigger scale and this sequence is a
really good example of how inception
influenced Doctor Strange because it
combines two memorable scenes from that
movie first notice how the City of
London bends and folds with the
architecture sliding into itself like a
Rubik's Cube just like how we see the
city of Paris do that in Inception but
also this fight scene is pretty much an
outdoor version of that inverted hallway
fight from inception with characters
using gravity and the rotation of the
space to their advantage but let's also
talk about the music
gyah Chino uses this overwhelming
cacophony of horns and brass and this
might sound familiar because it's
voguing the same memorable score from
the matrix Kevin Feige actually
mentioned the matrix is a huge
inspiration for this film story and
themes also the melody of Giacchino's
music reminds us of his score from Star
Trek
and this is also effective at
reproducing that sense of awe at the
spectacle that both of these movies have
and speaking of music I just love the
way Earth Wind & Fire's shining star
brings us into strangest cocky
personality he's literally this star
surgeon who's so relaxed that he can
play guessing games with songs during
complicated medical procedures now you
probably noticed how much these early
shots of the film focus on close-ups of
Strange's hands just like the recurring
taemin imagery that I discussed in the
other video hands are an important
visual cue that represents Strange's
character arc throughout this movie now
the screenwriters see Robert Cargill
said this whole movie is about healing
and the images are strange his hands
starting strong then breaking then
healing is parallel to his mental state
like right now when he's so Cavalier and
taking his hands for granted that all
reflects his arrogance like honestly you
could probably turn off the sound for
this movie and still understand most of
it just by looking at strangest hands
and I feel like I just inspired a new
type of fetish porn
sorry cumber buddy anyway moving on to
the scene where strange saves this
gunshot victim now we meet Christine
Palmer Rachel McAdams his character we
talked about this and the other videos
but in the comics Christine Palmer is
one of the three characters from the
night nurse series who helped dr.
strange and other Marvel heroes kind of
like Claire temple from the Marvel
Netflix shows we also meet dr. Nicodemus
West played by Michael Stuhlbarg this
guy is an amazing character actor who
also showed up in an amazing movie
arrival that you should definitely check
out now dr. rest is actually a character
from the Doctor Strange comic series
called The Oath West follows strange to
come our Taaj that learns from the
ancient one in secret he's actually kind
of a sneaky bad guy in that comic and I
don't think the character is going in
that direction here he's just kind of
arrival to strange the oath is great you
should definitely check it out because
it influenced a lot of this movie and I
talked about the significance of strange
telling West to cover his watch in the
other video so definitely check that out
but what do you think about it this
victim foreshadows what strange is about
to go through himself other people
declared this guy mentally brain-dead
but strange saw a way forward similarly
strange will see his life his
professional life at least pretty much
come to an end but he will refuse to
accept that finding all these risky but
possible solutions for a way forward
okay moving on to this wide shot of New
York City and just like we saw in the
trailer you can clearly make out Tony
Stark's Avengers tower now a lot of
people have been wondering when in the
MCU timeline this story takes place and
that a on the tower means it takes place
after the
into the first Avengers movie at least
at the earliest now I'll talk more about
this in a second but again I gotta talk
about the music here so this song is
interstellar overdrive' by Pink Floyd
and sampling Pink Floyd is another
connection of comics because Pink Floyd
used art from a Doctor Strange comic on
their cover for their album a Saucerful
of Secrets and that art actually shows
the Living Tribunal who's referenced in
this movie a little later on ok two of
the major Easter eggs in this movie come
up in this scene in the car with Billy
telling strange about possible new
patients the first is a 35 year old
airforce Colonel crushed his lower spine
and some kind of experimental armor now
a lot of people think this could be
referencing roadie war machine who
messed up his back something fierce
since of war but remember roadie was
back on his feet by the end of that
movie and Scott Derrickson himself said
that this isn't referring to war machine
and come on let's face it Don Cheadle
cannot pull off 35 37 maybe and other
people are saying that this could be
referring to that test pilot from Justin
hammers presentation back in Iron Man 2
remember hammer did say I'd like to
point out that that test pilot survived
but again we're getting into timeline
issues here because those events took
place back in 2010 and based on that
plaque that strange had and the year on
his watch this is all taking place in
2016 so my guess is that this could just
be one of those lines that sounds like a
reference but it actually isn't all
right like come on nerds not everything
is an easter egg
except this Easter Egg right here this
patient a 22-year old female with an
electronic implant in her brain to
control schizophrenia struck by
lightning now notice how strange is
interested but before we find out more
smash like ginger car accident now the
leading theory is that that 22-year old
female could be Carol Danvers
Captain Marvel who of course brie Larson
is gonna play now Kevin Feige did say
that they planned on changing captain
Marvel's origin story for the movie and
when scott derrickson was asked about
this he said quote all I can say is
maybe that one you're going to have to
wait and see which I interpret as yes
now I know this stills not speculative
but keep in mind the MCU has T's future
MCU heroes like this before like
remember in 2014 they quickly name-drop
Stephen strange a Captain America Winter
Soldier Bruce Banner Stephen strange
anyone who's a threat to Hydra so yes we
will see derrickson okay moving on so
Stephen strange is origin story with a
car accident destroying his hands is all
pretty much how it goes down in the
comics but I like how the movie replaced
his alcohol
ilysm with this fixation on using his
hands to operate all of his devices
while driving because it routes us back
and strange his hands as an expression
of his character and then as we see his
hands post accident scar destroyed
massive nerve damage it points directly
to the rock-bottom state strangest in
right now and as he goes through
physical therapy
notice how we only see him working to
strengthen his hands like his whole self
is only as useful as his hands are then
check out this shot of strange trying to
write his name this moment is taken
directly from J michael Straczynski
Doctor Strange comic it's cool way to
show how strange his identity is tied
directly to his ability to control his
hands I also learned that apparently
that is considered bad handwriting like
this is the best I could do took me two
hours whatever okay Benedict Cumberbatch
was obviously perfectly cast as Stephen
strange but that's not just because he's
great at playing snarky know-it-alls who
are still likable actually Cumberbatch
has said in interviews that he spent his
gap year as an English teacher in
Darjeeling India and that he used this
experience of being a foreign Westerner
in this part of the world to inform this
part of strangest journey and this
close-up of strange is broken watch
after that mugging attempt is symbolic
for his now shifting timeline and I get
into that in the other video but let's
talk about Mordo real quick in the
comics Baron Mordo is a recurring
villain which is why it's not too
shocking to see him turn bad in that
post-credit scene this movie was more
about showing more toes journey to
becoming an antagonist strange to give
any future conflict between them real
emotional stakes and as strange enters
Kimura Taj we meet Aamir the one-handed
sorcerer in the comics he's known as
mere the Hermit and he's actually Wong's
father but the director says that this
wasn't the case in this movie now this
whole sequence of strange flying through
the multiverse is one of my favorite
parts of the film
the production crew nicknamed the
sequence the magical mystery tour and
that is a reference to the Beatles
magical mystery tour which was an album
and song and tour in 1967 this was the
Beatles at the height of their
experimental psychedelic LSD fuelled
artistic phase which applies directly to
the psychedelic acid trip imagery were
seeing here and actually the visual
effects team said that this whole
sequence was supposed to be seven
minutes long and it was going to go into
arts of Steven Strange's past that might
have been why production shot scenes
with even strange his sister that didn't
end up making it into the film could
have been part of this section and they
said that
this is such a key part of a movie that
the editing department began working on
this before the movie was even filmed
now there's a lot of artistic influences
at play here surrett II mentioned Steve
Ditko's trippy illustrations in the
comics praising Ditko for using shapes
and colors in ways that were uncommon
for his time also apparently the 1940
Disney film Fantasia was another
additional influence on this film
psychedelic appearance now check out
this one dimension made up of hands
where strange experiences this
surrealist vision of hands coming out of
fingers again the hand imagery is
reflecting Strange's mental state the
infinite number of hands represents the
infant number of realities his mind is
expanding to perceive and this all seems
pretty light-hearted and fun and a big
reason for that is that Dan Harmon
helped consult on the script now Harmon
is known for brilliant sci-fi comedy on
shows like Rick and Morty and community
and Kevin Feige and scott derrickson
admitted that they brought on Harmon not
just for the jokes but for Harmons input
on the movies depiction of alternate
realities and the story beats because
Dan Harmon's just kind of a genius on
all this stuff and we know Harmon
specifically helped out with this scene
because when he spoke at Comic Con his
computer screen showed a number of dr.
strange related files including one
titled magical mystery and really when
you compare strangest journey through
the multiverse to similar moments of
Rick and Morty like that goodbye moon
man music video o world can be won
together
cosmos without hatred or really any of
the shows numerous interdimensional
chase scenes you could definitely see
Dan Harmon's influence also real quick
this one dimension with geometric
crystal shards this looks a lot like
that same quantum realm that we saw an
ant-man so even though this is a very
different film I love these little ways
that dr. strange connects to the MCU
okay moving on so this whole Kimura Taj
part of the movie is all of references
to the Doctor Strange comics so I'm
going to quickly point out the ones that
I notice so we pointed this out in the
other trailer breakdown but Shambhala as
the Wi-Fi password is referenced to the
Doctor Strange comic into Shambhala
which features Sameer and Doctor Strange
dealing with the death of the ancient
one and I love the way the portals
looked in this movie and the visual
effects team said that they really
wanted the portals to have this tactile
feel and those sparks that you see
dropping to the ground really made the
portals seem like something you could
touch and walk through and then Mordo
show strange the staff of the Living
Tribunal now the staff itself isn't in
the comics but the Living Tribunal is
it's this massive cosmic deity
it has this floating head with three
sides and it keeps all the dimensions in
balance Mordo also shows the faulting
boots of vault or again the boots are
new but Balto is this mysterious entity
that dr. strange references all the time
it's like magic that can be summoned in
the form of gas like the vapors of vault
or or like snakes the Vipers of all tour
he also mentions the wand of watoomb and
we actually see wang holding that later
the one of watoomb is one of strangest
artifacts in the comics it's controlled
by the thoughts of the user and
harnesses mystical energy to create or
deflect spells and then this whip that
strange harnesses and uses throughout
the movie could be the film's version of
the crimson bands of cyttorak now those
are read in the comics but strange uses
them in a similar way lassoing enemies
and blocking attacks we also see strange
in the library a lot and we get a look
at the ancient ones private collection
and notice how there's an empty slot now
some people are thinking that this might
belong to the dark hold
that's the mystical book from the show
agents of shield now a lot of you guys
are asking how much time exactly strange
spins training at Komara Tosh no it's
not entirely clear but the screenwriter
said that the tree income or Tosh
courtyard is a clue to the passage of
time so check it out when strange
arrives to come our Tosh the flowers in
the tree are just beginning to bud and
blossom suggesting that it's spring time
then later towards the end of his
training the leaves are brown like it's
autumn that means strange could train
from like February or March to October /
November so like around 7 or 8 months
now I know that isn't a very long time
but remember strange is a fast learner
he said that he had a photographic
memory and he's still very much a novice
when he tries to fight cry silliest in
the zealots later so he's still very
much in the process of his education
now I explained what's going on with
this eye of agamotto time loop sequence
the other video but it leads us to
Wong's explanation of the three sanctums
that protect Earth from Dormammu all
created by the original sorcerer supreme
agamotto
now this idea of three seems to be
derived from the comics where the seal
of Ashanti that symbol and skylight of
the New York sanctum is actually a union
of three powerful magical entities
called
austere hug off and a komodo now when
shrinked goes to the New York sanctum he
sees this guy Daniel drum now in the
comics Daniel drum was the brother and
later kind of spiritual assistant to
Jericho drum also known as brother
voodoo voodoo actually becomes the
sorcerer supreme for a short time in the
comics now this sanctum is full of
magical artifacts and if you look
closely you can see this
helmut this could be a nun colored
version of the Black Knights helmet
Black Knight is another Marvel hero and
the prop guy who worked on this film
said that black knights
evany blade was supposed to appear in
the movie but it was cut last minute we
also see that kycilia said his followers
use this weapon that could be the film's
version of the daggers of Dabba roth
which have more of a spell form in the
comics also notice how there are no guns
in this movie that's something
derrickson wanted saying quote there's
nothing less magical than a gun and
that's one of several common tropes that
he wanted to avoid when making Doctor
Strange
I'll get to the others as we go on and I
think what I like most about this fight
scene is that strange is getting his ass
kicked
he's totally outnumbered and that was
something intended by the screenwriter
unlike other superheroes who immediately
start kicking ass before they really
learn their skills he wanted strange to
be an underdog so that's why the only
way he wins this fight is by outsmarting
the zealots with the windows and then
getting lucky really with the cloak of
levitation and then this artifact that
strange briefly scares kycilia swift
before they both realize that he doesn't
know how to use it is the evil eye of
Avalon that's from the comics it can
manipulate matter on a molecular level
and fire a force blast it's used by
people like Prester John in the Marvel
Comics now let's talk about the cloak of
levitation in this movie it kind of has
sentience kind of like the magic carpet
in Aladdin that's not exactly the case
of the comics except the oath series
that I talked about before where it kind
of can think on its own and really here
it definitely has a clear personality
and it really saves Strange's neck over
and over again another thing that makes
this movie great is the depth to the
character of Kai Silius so as he
explains himself to strange his
rationale for summoning Dormammu and the
Dark Dimension makes sense in its own
weird way like he doesn't want the earth
to expire he wants this realm and
everyone in it to live forever like
strange he considers time to be an enemy
now this was intentional because
derrickson pitched kycilia as a villain
of ideas and watertight logic hoping
that he would stand out from the other
one-dimensional villains that we've seen
another MCU movies also I love the way
that he echoes a line strange says
earlier comparing the people he killed
to quote tiny moment I respects within
an addition universe which is exactly
what streams called human life when
ranting into the ancient one earlier
you're just another tiny momentary speck
within in a different universe basically
kycilia s-- is offering that classic
deal with the devil right like trying to
make the two of them sound more alive
then different now moving on this whole
scene with Christine Palmer operating on
strange while his astral form stands
over her is the same taken directly from
the oath and this awesome
astral fight is such a great scene and
it was actually part of scott derrickson
original pitch to marvel to get them to
let him make this movie and during this
viewer chase sequence we get our
standard Stan Lee cameo that is
hilarious that boogies reading is out as
Huxley's the doors of perception the
whole thing is an essay about a
psychedelic drug trip that Huxley
experienced so it's really an
appropriate choice for the scene with
trippy shots of the city folding onto
itself and actually this little scene
with Stanley was shot by James Gunn the
director of the guardians of the galaxy
movies James Gunn said that he shot two
other Stanley cameos for other Marvel
movies on the same day and I'm guessing
that they're the ones for guardians of
the galaxy volume 2 and maybe spider-man
homecoming and this chase gets
particularly insane to look at and the
visual effects guys ready cited the work
of MC escher as an influence he wanted
the buildings that were being distorted
to be made of material that we know so
if you look closely at this platform
that the ancient one reassembles out of
random chunks of New York you can see
the familiar subway station signs for
Wall Street and the Museum of Natural
History and the outer bands include
Green Street signs showing New York so
basically they broke down the city of
New York and the millions of pieces and
reassemble them like Legos and it looks
fantastic and at the end of the sequence
we see that the ancient one now has the
same marking our foreheads at the
zealots and kycilia salve meaning just
like them she pulls her power from the
Dark Dimension that symbol is kind of a
smoking gun for more dough to realize
the truth about the ancient one now
again I talked about the importance of
the scene with strange and the ancient
ones ash reforms in the other video
specifically how it relates to the theme
of time but I want to point out this one
shot that I just really loved the moment
the ancient one tells him it's not about
you the camera swings around who
repositioned strange from the left side
of the screen to the right it's at this
moment when strange realizes literally
what is right
sacrificing his selfish desire to heal
himself for the greater good of healing
the world and then these shots of
strange washing his hands and then using
them to cut Christine's face again his
hands show us where his mind is at
strange feels guilt for not being able
to save the ancient one like he has her
blood on his hands and he has to wash it
off and then he also
feels guilt for the way he treated
Christine and the pain he's caused her
and then real quick some of you Sherlock
fans might have caught this little nod
to the BBC show with strange popping the
collar the cloak of levitation just like
Sherlock does oh please can we don't do
this this time turning your coat collar
up so you look cool I don't do that yeah
you do actually this gag with the cloak
wiping away Sherlock's tears and
annoying him was a joke suggested by
Benedict Cumberbatch no I wish my
clothes would like automatically wipe
away my tears um nothing other anything
to okay no what I'm only therapy you
need therapy okay
moving on now in the scarab scene in
Hong Kong we get a few more references
to the Doctor Strange comics now as I
mentioned before Wong is holding the
wand of watoomb here but also we get
this quick shot of Tina Minoru who
showed up a few times earlier to she's
the mother of Nico Minoru who's part of
the Runaways comics here Tina holds the
staff of one which is the main weapon of
Nico in the comics moving on to this big
awesome finale sequence which I talked
about in the other video here we see one
of the ways scott derrickson wanted to
make Doctor Strange different from other
MCU movies so in those movies a city
always gets destroyed and the portal
needs to be closed and derrickson wanted
the opposite a city to be put back
together in the hero to go flying
through the portal to see what's on the
other side and the screenwriter added
that this all comes back to Doctor
Strange being a story about healing like
the one wait for strange to fix things
in the end is by healing the city
restoring it to its normal health much
like a surgeon would not like leaving it
and ruin and walking away to eat
shawarma now giacchino use a really cool
effect for the music in the scene notice
how the city moves in Reverse the music
we hear is reversed as well
and mirroring the northumberland fight
at the beginning of the movie this Hong
Kong fight shows the heroes using the
quirks of this new dimension to their
advantage with strange using the water
gushy back into the broken fish tank to
trap one zealot and the tiles of a
reassembling wall to trap an Chi Silius
now the look of the Dark Dimension in
this time loop sequence was designed by
the visual effects team based
specifically on one black light poster
that was inspired by Steve Ditko that
hung in Scott Derrickson office like
when you shine a black light on it it
glows with these neon colours derrickson
was adamant that the Dark Dimension have
that same neon color tone and then one
last possible reference to the Doctor
Strange comics when strange gets his
bargain with Dormammu and kycilia Sanu
zealots float into the Dark Dimension
noticed how their bodies turn gray and
ashy as these beams of light emit from
their heads that's kind of similar to
the appearance of the mindless ones from
the comics those are the beings that
dwell in the Dark Dimension along with
door mama and again check out my other
video for my breakdown on this time loop
stuff along with the closing images but
for now let's talk about the Infinity
stones now the eye of agamotto as the
time stone makes five out of six stones
revealed in the MCU and a lot of people
online have noticed an interesting
coincidence so we had the space stone in
the tesseract and then the mine stone
before it was used to create vision in
Loki's scepter and then the reality
stone in the ether and then the power
stone in the orb and then the time stone
in the eye of agamotto necklace so the
first letters of all those words come
together to form to say on stone ax
tones or I guess
Thanos with the missing H would make a
little bit more sense so if this Thanos
theory is true and admittedly this could
all be able if that leaves some H out
there in the MCU as the location of the
remaining soul stones and one popular
theory is that H could refer to Heimdall
the gatekeeper of Asgard and the Thor
movies now he is blind but he has the
ability to see souls wherever they are
in the universe and having the soul
stone in his head could be how he does
that and why his eyes appear to be
orange now it doesn't sound like the
soul stone will appear in guardians to
the galaxy vol 2 this summer leaving it
up to Thor Ragnarok as the most likely
film to reveal it so if this Heimdall
theory ends up being true
it'd be like a super nerdy but awesome
way for the MCU to reveal each of the
Infinity stones okay that is all I got
and thanks for watching them one last
time be sure to check out my breakdown
to the Indian sequence of time theory
and the post-credits scenes if you liked
this video please hit like and subscribe
to new rock stars you can also
contribute to us on patreon thank you so
much all of our current patrons every
monthly donation helps us out a ton no
matter how small so really we love you
guys thank you so much you can hit me up
on Twitter a TA boss with any thoughts
or questions you had on Doctor Strange
or follow new rock stars on Twitter at
new rock stars for information on our
future videos okay thanks for watching
bye
[Music]